alors comment est ce que vous accueillez
les nouvelles annonces du premier
ministre
bah y'a pas grand chose en fait ça et on
sculpte une manière de répondre réalité
n'y a pas grand chose la question moi ce
que j'accueille en fait c'est vis-à-vis
de tous les politiques et ce qu'on a
devant aussi c'est en fait qu'est ce
qu'on cherche à avoir
moi je suis médecin donc on va me
demander qu'est ce que vous pensez du
confinement
je suis médecin donc depuis le début je
réagis aux médecins j'ai vu des études
on a parlé de raul tout à l'heure donc
je suis médecin je sais lire un article
on va reparler brown et donc on lit les
articles et on voit ce qu'il ya à les
médecins ils travaillent comment ils
travaillent sur des articles
scientifiques
comment des tests ont fait des vrais
articles un pad et des trucs publié dans
des mauvaises journaux comme celui de
raout ou d'autres et au pardon ou le
vôtre d'ailleurs puisque madame bonheur
a publié un super article dans un
journal où on a des copains qui ont
publié la semaine date deux semaines
après un article sur les faibles hydroxy
chloroquine sur les trottinettes donc
pas ce genre de canard mais des vrais
journaux accord lie je vois que ça
commence non mais une victime car le
long des conventions de l'est mais
j'aimerais qu'on s'engueule dans le
calme et l'ordre à d'abord attendre est
votre réaction
je suis médecin donc pour arrêter la
circulation du virus
il n'y a pas il n'ya pas à tortiller il
ya deux façons de faire soit on confine
c'est comme ça c'est la vision jeudi du
côté médical sont confine s'en protège
les agents avec de l'immunité l'immunité
c'est la vaccination voilà point barre
après c'est la même chose quand je dis
au genre ouais faut pas boire d'alcool
parce que c'est un avis médical corps
donc vous auriez que d'un point de vue
médical vous auriez préféré que le
premier ministre annonce un confinement
général d'un point de vue médical ça
dépend de l'objectif si l'objectif c'est
d'arrêter la transmission du virus aux
riches est l'objectif
si l'objectif c'est d'arrêter la
transmission du virus en attendant qui
est un vaccin
eh ben on confine c'est exactement ce
qu'ont fait les israéliens ils ont
confiné et ils ont commencé à vacciner
avec des résultats qui sont plutôt bons
ça se voit et donc là on essaye de faire
la chèvre et le chou en fait
sachant qu'en fait moi je vois tout un
tas de gens qui disent à fos déconfite
et fausse des confiné en réalité en
région parisienne en tout cas là où je
vis on n'est pas vraiment confiné il ya
un vague couvre-feu de 18h et basta quoi
alors comment vous expliquez que qu'on
ne voit là on n'opte pas pour cette
solution du conflit
non mais ça ça la limite de tous les
médecins qui sont assis à votre place
disent à peu près la même chose et une
seule technique en réalité à aller mais
c'est le confinement dans 99 % des
médecins dans cette crise on dit la même
chose on a juste donné la voie à un but
au 1% qu'ils n importe quoi mais en fait
mais parce que c'est notre avis c'est un
avis technique quand vous allez quand
votre voiture les pneus à plat vous
regardez la voiture vous dites il faut
gonfler les pneus
c'est un avis pique nique après on est
aussi citoyen on a aussi envie d'aller
au resto on a aussi envie d'aller au
bistrot on a envie de sortir d'aller au
théâtre on est des citoyens aussi mais
on nous demande notre avis comme
technicien notre avis médical
d'épidémiologie de techniques moi mon
service il déborde de passion qu vide
moi ça me fait marrer tous les gens
qu'il y aura à la poubelle baisse c'est
pas vrai depuis deux semaines on galère
pour trouver des lits on a hospitalisé
des patients auraient à la nos patients
ils ont jamais notre ray allen n'a pas
été aussi pleine
je pense depuis la première vague pas la
deuxième avec des patients beaucoup plus
jeunes qu'avant et là on a parlé de
l'opti flausch pas si vous vous souvenez
on a dit on à tubes et plus les patients
parce que on avait une étape
supplémentaire qui est en gros du haut
débit d'oxygène on n'avait pas mis la
première fois parce qu'on avait peur que
ça affecte tout le monde en fait et donc
là maintenant on fait ça mais ça suffit
plus haut là je crois qu'il y avait
seize ou dix-sept patients ce matin dans
notre animation qui était un tube et sur
le ventre
c'est ça la réalité d'une épidémie la
réalité on peut parler chiffres ça monte
de 1% sa baisse de 1%
c'est pas ça la réalité d'une épidémie
c'est des gens qui sont malades
heureusement beaucoup sont peu
symptomatique ou asymptomatiques et il y
en a qui sont très malades qui sont pas
des patients violents qui sont des
patients alors la moyenne d'âge ici quoi
la cinquantaine et la soixantaine et
c'est des patients jeunes c'est le
patient qui travaillent c'est pas c'est
pas des prostituées à gâteau prouve
aujourd'hui franchement gl qui fait
baisser la moyenne mais j'ai surpris
quand même une petite mouche où il
connaît la maison
des gens aussi con des facteurs de
risques qu'ils prennent des immuno sur
les choses que les docteurs ès qu'est-ce
que depuis le début de l'année l'a donc
depuis janvier 2021
vous avez été confronté à ce choix de
déprogrammer certains sont en chômage
aux autres que coville alors vous donne
un essai c'est par un exemple c'est ce
qui se passe dans mon service donc je
vais être technique mon unité
d'hospitalisation des urgences elle est
entre la réanimation les urgences très
bien eh bien on a repris cette unité on
l'avait déjà fait lors des deux
dernières vagues pour en faire ce qu'on
appelle une unité de soins continus
c'est à dire la réanimation n'inclut pas
les gens pour être vraiment basique et
mon unité d'hospitalisation elle a
déménagé beaucoup plus loin dans le
service d'orthopédie donc actuellement
des infirmières d'orthopédie délit
d'orthopédie sont dévolues à des
patients de médecine dont ce matin je
crois que j'avais ouais la moitié
étaient covic je pense que ça va être
bien ce stade critique où vous devez
hiérarchiser entre les patients les
priorités là bien sûr et on transfère en
réanimation là nous on a pu place en
réanimation on avait un patient qui
était hospitalisé je parle pas d'un
patient de travaux d'urgence qu'on a
descendu aux urgences pour le technique
et parce qu'il ya plus de places en
réanimation
et puis après on a attendu l'ambulance
pendant des heures pour qu'il aille dans
une autre et animations on en est là
c'est donc les idées de ouais on
continue c'est la fête du slip ben sinon
quand on est là aujourd'hui dont on
attendait juste un instant jusqu'à c'est
une épidémie en m'ont donné qu'en est il
qu'en est il aujourd'hui des 2000 lits
qui ont été fermés pendant l'année dans
le sud s'est-t-il et la finition et il
est dit bill des 10000 respirateur qui
n'en auraient dû être commandée il ya au
mois d'avril de l'année dernière alors
qu'en est il de la formation de
nouvelles infirmières pour justement pas
une erreur c'est les artisans
aujourd'hui on est tributaire d'une
nouvelle jambe de
c'est vous dire vous dirigez pas où ils
sont et j'espère qu'ils sont là la
question c'est que là on essaye de faire
pas comme la première vague on affermi
2000 lits non mais que c'est des
millions de rappels s'est effondré c'est
pas 2010 c'est pas disponible c'est des
lits de soins de suite ya aussi enfin on
mélange beaucoup de choses dans ses
lilas la question c'est de toute façon
on est en l'épidémie la question à l'est
pas on va ouvrir des lits dre à ce que
vous comprenez pas là un patient par les
mêmes choses que vous ne saviez bien un
patient sur trois ans il ya un vous
dites n'importe quoi depuis le début
donc c'est bon ça fait un nom faut
s'arrêter maintenant mes docteurs a joué
tout le monde et la parole non mais
c'est le monde arabe et le monologue du
confinement bon sens et moi non mais
franchement c'est pas comme si un
patient de réassurance swiss re docteur
c'est le truc c'est de pas y aller quoi
vous comprenez la sas erreur sur ma
fille chili a marqué mathias wargon le
gouvernement at il bien géré la crise du
corona virus vous votez oui ça fait ça
j'ai goûté oui je dis ni oui ni non j'en
sais rien j'en sais rien on comptera les
vaches les blues à la fin du à la fin de
la foire